this is a pretty standard well what you
need you learn the volume of a cone you
ten maybe yeah the case is a pretty
standard question you might have faced a
couple of years ago okay
but we're interested in more than that
we don't just want to know how big the
whole thing is and we have the tools to
work out a lot more about this right for
instance now I am gonna have to go back
to some calculus stuff okay what you see
this this is a shorthand isn't it what's
a shorthand for so this is it's a it's
showing it for a couple of things
actually I mean I suppose you could say
it's the derivative of Y with respect to
X that's a very very abstract way of
saying but it's correct okay oh where
did that idea come from though think
back to first principles what give these
DS why are they DS what do they stand
for they stand for Delta which is about
a change right so this is about rise
over run and we did our you don't we did
our diagram you've got some function and
you're thinking about rise over run and
you want to make this interval right
above this width you want to make it
increasingly small up right and once you
get to zero you approach the limit
that's when you get the derivative
instantaneous sort of rate of change
okay or rather an instantaneous green
okay so being that rise over run just
means how much Y changes in proportion
to that's what a fraction is right it's
a proportion that's why they called
rational numbers ratios right in
proportion to how much X changes okay
now you told me right or at least I
tried that in here we have some
information about two things that change
in relation to each other right there's
a few things actually right what might
be a good place to start where do we
have the most information
hmm I'm thinking is probably the pouring
rain I think that's what we know the
most about okay now to be honest I have
no IDE
you how long it took me to an opinion
though I suppose I could make a guess
how long did it take for me to pour the
whole thing 20 seconds about 20 seconds
okay so if I know that this is the
volume roughly okay and it took me about
20 seconds to pour the whole thing okay
what might be an appropriate number like
you know in terms of centimeters cubed
that's a that's a pouring rate isn't it
right per second how many cubic
centimeters was i pouring in every
second roughly divided by 20 right about
108 right I suppose we're a bit off
because that three six one nine right
but it's all sort of approximations
let's call it 180 180 per second is that
consistent that sound about right
how much is 180 cubic centimeters 580
mils hundred eighty meals
how BIG's a cup like a cup of water that
250 isn't it like 2/3 of a cup this I
mean we with wet picturing a bigger cone
are we so yeah I think we're in the
right ballpark so let's call this how
much the volume changed of water in
there right over how much what now the
thing is the the rate tells you doesn't
it the rate itself tells you here you
have a volume right and here do you have
a time geog centimeters seconds right so
the unit's telling you what kind of a
rate of change you have so this is DV on
DT is that okay can we accept that okay
this is interesting
right now be careful I'm gonna rub off
some stuff off the board in a second
because I don't think I'll be useful to
us anymore and in fact it will actually
be confusing what is DB on duty or
rather what's what to be in this case
hmm be careful because it's not the
volume of the cone is er because the
volume of the cone is this how does this
change with respect to time answer it
doesn't it's always that morning isn't
it it's been that volume the whole time
I've been talking and has it changed
right so this volume this V is talking
about the whole thing but that's not
what this is right what's this V this is
the volume of the water that's actually
in there and that's changing does that
make sense
hmm be careful of these kinds of things
so therefore I'm gonna get rid of all of
this because it's not gonna be useful to
us afterwards right and I better when
I'm talking about letters here I better
say what they are right so let's say
this let V equal and I'll call it the
volume of water that's in there even the
glass whoops sorry
after well I'm talking about a time as
well right so I might as well relate
these to each other because apparently
they are so it's the volume of water in
the glass after I'm talking in terms of
seconds on it that number of seconds
okay all right so now I've got some
variables here I've got a rate of change
okay but I don't yet have any related
rates of change there are some other
rates of change happening in this
scenario
aren't there what kinds of other things
can you see there's hi we identified
that didn't read right and we said we
may we draw certain we drew some
observations about it okay what's the
height now we're interested in this you
USA the height was changing with respect
to what over time right
as time passes the height gets well it
increases yes hmm
but this is a problem where do we get
this expression from we got it from the
fact that we were will make an
observation at a time okay and we know
what the volume the whole thing is so we
got a number out okay how will we do
this we can't quite do it the same way
we did it before
can we okay because as you noticed if I
do the same thing make the same argument
I've got a height right and I can say
well 24 centimeters right and it took
what do we say 20 seconds three seconds
over 20 seconds okay so you know I say
that height over that time that's what
sorry one point two centimeters per
second that's what that's what it looks
like I would get but it's not why not
because as you told me before the rate
of height increase how much this this
thing is right it's lowered down right
it started off quite quickly didn't it
and then as it got to this top you were
like gosh what's is this ever gonna get
to the top right actually I wasn't sure
if we get to the spot didn't know if I
had before now this thing here this
doesn't change this is a cluster it's
always 1.2 it's like it sort of goes up
and gradual rate and never slows down or
never speeds up so this is not D H or DT
right hmm so therefore how can we get
expression for D etre meeting and draw
some conclusions about it right we need
some more information on this diagram so
we've got some concrete measurements
okay but I want to introduce some
changing measurements okay so if I put
in put in this sorry I want to talk
about H in a second right and H is
something that changes it's not 24 how
do you think I should define H
think about the way I defined V I want H
to be a changing thing maybe the height
of the water in the glass after T
seconds so corresponds to V doesn't it
so is the height of not back home but
the height of the water that's in there
okay now here's the thing though because
it's cone when I put water in the water
will also be in the shape of a cone
right you've got similarity all the way
up so let's draw a point in time okay
something like this there's some water
in there okay so now I can put some
measurements on you cannae okay I'm
calling the height of this big yeah I'm
calling that H right now if I want to
work out the volume of the water V the
video that I'm talking about right
Helena work out the volume of this code
down here what your formation do I need
if I want a volume of a cone you told me
about five minutes ago but the volume of
a clue is PI R squared H right okay now
we're talking about our via that's why I
put it in another color okay this volume
of water that's changing okay now I know
what H is I'm calling it H okay but
what's the radius can you see why I
picked the numbers there you know what's
the radius going to be when I get to the
end when I get to the end whatever time
after twenty seconds okay my H will be
24 and my R will be twelve
yes because I'm finished is the whole
thing right at the beginning my height
zero and my radius is also zero okay but
in between there we have a whole bunch
of similar cones don't we they're all
similar to each other because they're
all in the same kind of shape yes
Sabir the relationship between those two
numbers is that the radius at the top is
half of the height okay and all of these
cones as I go up will be similar
okay what's the radius going to be at
some arbitrary pointed here well it's
going to be hard for the height isn't it
that's what similarity means okay all of
the sides will always be the same
proportionate if the radius is half of a
height somewhere along these in one of
these similar shapes then the radius
will always be half of the height okay
good so now I could say what's the
volume the volume is now what's the
radius is H 1 to H on 2 squared times H
let's just tie you that up a little bit
okay squid on four isn't it it's going
to the 4 so I'm going to get by the
looks of it 1 12 pi H cute is that ok
all right now if I know this I can make
some statements because V the volume and
H the height are connected to each other
right so if they're connected to each
other as the height of the water changes
the volume changes and vice versa right
so this equation represents a
relationship that I can manipulate
because I can do this right
sorry wrong color I can work out that
color because this is just going back to
calculus stuff there's an expression
with any point and an output right so I
could different yet Connor what's the
derivative
well it's I'm wit H so this three comes
out the front right so it'll be a
quarter pi is just a constant and then
it'll be H squared right this is a
little bit weird because they're so used
to think in terms of X's and Y's okay
but you know it's just a two variable
function dressed up in different clothes
that's what we can do all the same rules
okay now what was i after I was after D
H on DT wasn't it wasn't how the height
is changing okay do you see now I
actually have enough information to work
out the H on DT can you see it
think back which piece of of knowledge
that you know is going to be relevant
here smooth the other way of saying you
can see it boy
it has a name it's called chain rule
isn't it think about what's happening I
have to to reproduce here two
derivatives okay and they have all of
the pieces I want there's an H yep
there's a T there so I should be able to
combine them to get the dhrd T yes
how am I gonna do it what's chain rule
gonna look like th o DV because I need
the d H on the top don't I
okay x DV r dt right now I almost have
these donor I've got my DV DT check it's
just a number they actually may I don't
quite have that I've got its reciprocal
but no problems I've been teaching you
seven about reciprocals originally I
think you guys can do a reciprocal
what's the reciprocal of DV on the H
it's four on pi H sweat isn't it times
DV on DT what times 18 what's that 72 so
that's 720
now let's stop for a little bit shall we
and observe okay what does this tell us
assuming we've done everything correct
all of these sort of hold and everything
makes sense apparently what can you
observe about our about our wine glass
and the water inside it from the maths
what does the maths
tell you this is how much the height is
changing how much the height is changing
and this kind of function well what does
it look like
well for starters H can't equal zero on
that function Canon right why would that
be because when H equals zero when
there's there water in their house the
height increasing well hmm
it's not increase it's not increasing
its not decreasing I have no idea what
it's doing what do anything okay so this
is not too fine when H equal zero but I
can draw it it looks like for the rest
of it this be careful by the way what am
I axes going to be we're so used to x
and y axes we just kind of do it once
don't we what my students okay so this
one's going to be DHI VT isn't it that's
what we're plotting on the vertical and
this is going to be H so we're thinking
about what happens to the rate of the
height change quite increase okay as the
high decreases now we already
established didn't we then it's not to
find that H equals zero
okay so there's an asymptote there what
happens as H increases
the denominators getting bigger so the
whole number is getting smaller isn't it
right so it's doing this kind of thing
isn't that that sort of accurate yeah
hmm no by the way I know that it looks
like this and not like this a linear
rate can anyone tell me why it doesn't
look like that what kind of shape is
this we have language to describe this
kind of thing what is it it's a
hyperbola isn't it of kinds right and we
know how peppers have this sort of curve
in shape and it also matches this kind
of video here that we saw right so it's
not just slowing down it's going down
and it's slowing down right now there's
a problem with my graph there is a
problem with my graph can anyone spot it
what you think out all the things we
observed right even the most obvious
things and what my graph is telling you
what our graph is telling us what am I
counted for I've accounted for this
discontinuity I have accounted for how
it's decreasing which should tell me
something like this shape right but
what's happening over here it doesn't
keep going forever does it right
it stops somewhere because you thought
oh you laughed but it's important it
overflowed right so the volume of water
in the glass it has a finite limit
doesn't it it gets to a point namely 24
let's just call it that and it stops
that's all it does 24 ok that's me weird
isn't it we're not used to graphs like
that but guess what welcome to the
physical world this is what graphs do in
the physical world ok